[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم مساء الخير معالي
الدكتور اهلا وسهلا انا عندي يعني سؤال
الحقيقه انا كان عندي مخطط اخر لاستئناف
الحلقات مع حضرتك ولكن في سؤال بيلاحقني
في التعليقات ويعني من مصادر متعدده
السؤال ده خلاصته قناعه البعض ان عمليه
طوفان الاقصى ليست الا
مؤامره وان حماس فعلت ذلك خدمه
للفلسطينيين خدمه للاسرائيليين وان
المساله تمت بتوافق اسرائيلي حمساوي حتى
يتم تقويد القضيه الفلسطينيه وعلى حساب
الشعب الفلسطيني والمؤامره بتمتد كمان
لتطال مصر اللي هيتم فيها
توطين الفلسطينيين وبقطع النظر عن انه ناس
بيتكلموا عن التفاصيل وكانهم كانوا حاضرين
يعني في جلسات الاعداد للمؤامرات المنطق
ده كيف ترى حضرتك ا اولا اشكر حضرتك يا
استاذ سيد على الاستضافه اولا وعلى طرح
هذا الموضوع شديد الاهميه ثانيا لانه
للاسف حين لا يكون الوعي
بالقضايا المحوريه في حياتنا كاملا لدى
الجميع ا
بيسهل طرح مثل هذه الافكار التي يمكن
بسهوله تفنها علميه معروف انه في العلاقات
الدوليه وفي السياسه عموما فكره المؤامره
بتطرح احيانا بالحاح غير علمي يعني البعض
ينظر الى كل شيء باعتباره مؤامره ما اريد
توضيحه انه في العلاقات الدوليه احنا دا
دايما بنقول ان العلاقات الدوليه لها
كلمتان
مفتاحان المصلحه
والقوه كل فاعل دولي لديه مصالح يحقق منها
ما تمكنه منه قوته وبالتالي هو في بعض
الاحيان في التفاعلات الدوليه تحدث صدامات
يعني التفاعلات الدوليه اما تعاونيه واما
صراعيه وقد تخفي بعض الدول نواياها من
قبيل الخداع لانها يريد ان تحقق مصالحها
البعض يستسهل ان كل هذا يمكن ان يطلق
عليه مؤامره ومن ضمن تداعيات هذا المنطق
الكلام اللي حضرتك تفضلت به طبعا المؤامره
موجوده في السياسه وموجوده في العلاقات
الدوليه ولكن اطلاقها على يعني بهذا
المعنى لا يكون علميا في كثير من الحالات
يعني م مثلا في
تاريخ الصدامات
العسكريه بين مصر واسرائيل يكاد مفهوم
المؤامره الا ينطبق الا على عدوان
1956 لانه تم اتفاق سري بين اسرائيل
وبريطانيا وفرنسا لم تطلع عليه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وكانت المؤامره كما
نعلم ان تقوم اسرائيل بهجوم على حدودها
معنا في سيناء ف يندفع الجيش المصري
لملاقاتها فتوجه بريطانيا وفرنسا انذاره
ما الى مصر بحجه حمايه الملاحه في قناه
السويس ويقع الجيش المصري في مصيده بين
القوات الاسرائيليه في الشمال الشرقي وبين
القوات البريطانيه والفرنسيه على ضفاف
القناه هذا يمكن ان نطلق عليه مؤامره ا ل
لكن مثلا يعني حرب
67 يقال انه افتعلت موضوع الحشود لكي
تستدرج مصر للدفاع عن سوريا
وتتم معايرتها بان هناك قوات طوارئ دوليه
فيضطر الرئيس عبد الناصر الى طلب سحب
القوات فيسهل ضرب
ا مصر التي كانت تجربتها ودورها في النظام
العربي قد بلغت رو خصوصا مع قرب انسحاب
بريطانيا من
ا عدن ومن الخليج العربي ا كله هذه انا لا
اسميها مؤامره انا اسميها اداره للصراع
انت لك مصالح وتحاول ان تحققها مصر عبد
الناصر تمثل لك يعني مشكله معينه وتريد
الخلاص منه وانت يعني تقوم بالتنسيق
الولايات المتحده مع حلفتها اسرائيل مثلا
بهذا العمل هذه اداره
للصراع من الطبيعي ان تكون سريه اريد ان
اذكر حضرتك ان نفس الكلام الذي لا اريد ان
استخدم الفاظ قاسيه في وصفه نفس الكلام
قيل عن حرب اكتوبر قيل ان حرب اكتوبر كانت
تمثيليه بين الرئيس السادات والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه نقوم بعمل ما يحرك
الامور وما الى هذا وطبعا عندما نطلع على
تفاصيل الاستعدادات لحرب اكتوبر بدءا من
المعارك الاولى بعد الهزيمه ثم حرب
الاستنزاف ثم حرب اكتوبر ذاتها نجد او
نتاكد انه الى اي مدى
هذه المساله مستبعده اذكر ايضا بما قيل من
انه احداث ا 11 سبتمبر 2001 كانت بتواطؤ
من من اجهزه ما في الولايات المتحده لكي
تبرر لجورج بوش الابن ان يفعل ما فعلوا في
افغانستان والعراق اذا فكر المؤامره موجود
والملاحظه الاولى عليه ان من يتحدثون بهذا
الفكر او وفقا لهذه الطريقه لا يملكون
الادله يعني لكي تثبت ان هناك تحريضا ما
اتفاقا ما الى اخر هذه الامور يجب ان تكون
عليك عندك الاسانيد
والا علينا ان نعمل العقل في تفسير ما جرى
اعود اذا الى
ا حديث المؤامره عن طوفان الاقصر من سيك
من سيكونون اطراف هذه المؤامره ما هو حماس
فصيل مقاوم وله علاقات طيبه باراده
وهي طبعا خصم لاسرائيل وانا واعن تماما
بما يقال من ان اسرائيل ساهمت في نشاه
حماس
وترعرع لكي توازن بها منظمه التحرير
الفلسطيني قد يكون هذا صحيحا ولكنه حماس
نشات ومارست المقاومه وهي التي اكبرت
اسرائيل مع غيرها من الفصائل الفلسطينيه
طبعا المقاومه اجبرت اريل شارون على ان
ينسحب من قطاع غزه والمستوطنات القريبه
المحيطه به في سابقه هي الاولى من نوعها
السابقه ممكن تكون الثانيه بقى بعد
الانسحاب من
لبنان لا انا اقصد تحديدا على المستوطنات
السابقه الاولى من نوعها انه لاول مره
اسرائيل تفكك مستوطنات مضطره وكان وكان
فيها مستوطنه لا اذكر اسمها لكن شارون
شارون مره عندما سئل هل تفكك هذه
المستوطنه قال افكك تل ابيب ولا افكك لكن
الطره في النهايه تحت ضربات المقاومه التي
تتهم بالتواطؤ مع اسرائيل انه يفكك هذه
المستوطنات اعود الى كلامي من سيكونون
اطراف هذه المؤامره حماس اسرائيل ايران
مثلا طيب فلنم سك طرفا طرفا يعني يعني انا
شاهدت شريط شاهدت شريطا يقول في شخص اعتقد
انه اما اسرائيلي او امريكي لان الشريط
كان مكتز جدا لكنه يحاول ان
يوحي ان ما حدث في الساعات الاولى من
طوفان الاقصى لا يمكن الا ان يكون يعني
فيه نوع من التواطئ يعني هو بدا الشريط
بان يقول يعني كيف حدث كذا وكذا وكذا
الانجازات الرائعه للمقاومه ثم يجيب على
نفسه في النهايه ويقول اجابتي انه لابد ان
يكون قد سمح له لانه مش ممكن ينتصر على
اسرائيل هذا طبعا معناه اولا استخفاف
بقدرات المقاومه والتعظيم من شان اسرائيل
يعني لا ده كمان بقى فيها نوع من الخيانه
من الداخل الاسرائيلي يعني من الذي سيسمح
لهم ما هو يعني يجوز تكون دوائر اسرائيليه
فهذه الافكار
عاده يعني يقصد بها التهوين من شان انفسنا
يعني كيف نتصور ان حماس تقبل ان تتعرض لكل
هذا الضرب لكي تشارك في مؤامره من شانها
القضاء عليها يعني كيف يستقيم
هذا المنطق وكيف تشارك اسرائيل ولو او جهه
ما داخل اسرائيل في هذه المساله وقد تم
اذلالها في الساعات الاولى من العمليه
ونحن
الان نحن الان بعد حوالي 10 ايام اكثر من
بدء العمليه وما زالت حماس والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه صامدين فكيف تقبل اسرائيل هذا
ا ايران مثلا ذات العلاقه الطيبه بحماس
هل يعقل ان تكون قد اوعزت اليها بهذه
العمليه وهي تعلم موازين القوه بين يعني
او مدى القوه الاسرائيليه ولماذا لا توعز
لحزب الله مثلا بان يفعل هذا في لبنان
يعني هناك قدر من الرشاده لابد ان نتذكره
في تحليلنا للامور ايران تملك قوه عسكريه
ضاربه وحزب الله يملك قوه عسكريه ضاربه
فلماذا لم تشتر
في الحرب حتى الان لان هناك نوع من
الرشاده في التفكير توسيع نطاق الحرب
ستترتب عليه تداعيات كذا وكذا وكذا طيب لو
ايران
بتحرض حماس كيف ستقبل انه فصيل ذو علاقه
طيبه بها ويمكن ان يساعدها في تنفيذ
سياستها في الشرق الاوسط يتم ضربه وتقويض
فاذا يعني حليلنا لكل الدوافع الممكنه
يشير الى ان هذه فكره غير
معقوله منطقيا طبعا انا
مقدر لما يقال من ان كل هذا الافتعال
تمهيد لدفع الفلسطينيين في غزه الى
المغادره غزه في اتجاه مصر وهذا هدف
اسرائيلي معروف وصرحوا به في
الوقت الاخير لكن كيف ستكون حماس شريكا في
هذه المؤامره والموقف الفلسطيني في مجمله
سواء السلطه الفلسطينيه سواء حماس سواء
المملكه الاردنيه سواء مصر واهم شيء
الفلسطينيون انفسهم في قطاع غزه لان
تجربه النكبه في
1948 ثم تجربه التهجير بعد او بعد هذ
67 من
الضفه الغربيه الى الضفه الشرقيه كل هذه
لها دروس محدده انه من يذهب لا يعود او
تكون عودته عمليه صعبه جدا من الناحيه
التاريخيه اختم
كلامي بنقطه معينه ان حديث
المؤامره
يدنا ان نؤمن
بفكرتين كلاهما سيء
وخطير
الفكره
الاولى انه
يعني
نتجاهل السبب الاصيل لما حدث السبب الاصيل
لما حدث ان هناك احتلالا للاراضي
الفلسطينيه تجاوز عمره نصف القرن من
1967 2017 كان فات 50 سنه يعني نحن الان
نتحدث عن 56 سنه وفي هذه المده الطويله في
هذه العقود العديده مارست اسرائيل ابشع
لديها من سياسات قمح الذين يتحدثون عن
حديث المؤامره يريدوننا ان ننسى ان طوفان
الاقصى وغيرها من عمليات المقاومه التي
سبقتها والمقاومه التي
ستلحق نتيجه للاستعمار نتيجه للاحتلال
الفلسطيني الرساله السيئه الثانيه ان ما
حدث من انجاز في طوفان الاقصى لا يمكن ان
يكون نتيجه للقدرات الذاتيه للمقاومه لابد
ان هذه تمثيليه لابد ان وكلاهما فكرتان
مرفوضان انا عاز استاذن حضرتك ان انا
استنتج يعني انا اكون افكر بمنطق الفريق
اللي بيعتقد ان هذه مؤامره وطره على حضرتك
استنتاجا يعني انا معرفش كل الناس دول
بيفكروا ازاي ولكن انا في تقديري ثلاث
اعتبارات الاعتبار الاول هو كره لجماعه
حماس واحيانا هذا الكره يمتد لجماعات
فلسطينيه اخرى لاسباب يطول شرحها وبالتالي
اي حاجه هتعملها حماس فهم بيحاولوا يعني
يفتشوا في النوايا ويفسرها بشكل
سلبي وخاصه لو كان عندك رغبه في التطبيع
ومش عاوز حد يفسد عليك هذه الرغبه ده
تقديري رقم واحد وطبعا فيها جزء منه بمجرد
ان حماس فصيل له انتماءات عقائديه معينه
فحتى لو فعل شيء جيد فالناس بتشكك فيه
وطبعا في رافض اخر لكراهيه حماس لا يخفى
على احد وهو ارتباطها وعلاقتها بايران
وعلاقه ايران متوتره بعدد من الدول
العربيه فهذا رافض اخر لكراهيه حماس اثنين
انه في خلط قديم ولو حضرتك تحب توضحه يا
ريت انه الناس بيجيبوا استشهادات قديمه
لنتنياهو
وزعماء فلسطينيين مختلفين بيتحدث فيه على
ان حماس افضل شريك لهم في التعامل مع
القضيه الفلسطينيه استاذنك اوضح ده وحضرتك
لو تحب تعلق عليه كل الكلام اللي قاله
نتنياهو على انها شريك جيد وانه احنا
وجدنا ضلت انا في حماس المقصود به
كالاتي ان حماس جماعه مقاومه وهي مقاومه
اصيله وليست عميله لا الاسرائيليين
بيقولوا كده ولا غيرهم بيقول كده ولكن
مجرد ان انت بتقاوم فهذا يعطي اسرائيل
الفرصه انه يتنصل من فكره السلام وحل
الدولتين الى اخره لكن حتى لو كانت حماس
مش موجوده هو هيبحث عن سبب اخر فكون انه
بيتكلم على ان انا ان انا حتى ادعم حماس
او يسمح بدخول لان وجودها يعزز تصوره
للتنصل من فكره السلام وحل
الدولتين السبب الثالث اللي بيخلي الناس
يعتقدوا ان هي مؤامره هي النتائج انه انت
عملت عمليه الاقصى وطوفان الاقصى وانك انت
طبعا باغتت الاسرائيليين والحقت بهم خسائر
غير مضبوطه غير مسبوقه لكن العواقب اللي
ترتبت على ده امر بشع جدا ويعتقدوا ان هذا
قد يصب او يوفر بيئه الاسرائيليين يقدروا
يحققوا فيها مخططات كانت مجمده زي تهجير
الغزاويين انا اسف ان انا اطلت يعني لكن
قناعتي ان دول هم الثلاث اسباب يعني والله
يا استاذ سيد حضرتك اثرت موضوعات في منتهى
الاهميه
والخطوره وساحاول قدر طاقتي ان اناقش هذه
الموضوعات اول شيء ا ما
اسميته ان كراهيه حماس يمكن ان تكون هي
الدافع لهذه المقولات
وانا وافق حضرتك انه هناك
دوائر على يعني صدام مع حماس فكرا
وممارسات وكل هذه الامور وانا ساكون شديد
الوضوح في هذا انا اذكر ان استاذي الجليل
الله يرحمه الدكتور حامد ربيع وعندما كنت
طالبا في
السنه الثالثه بالكليه
ا كان يدرس لنا النظريه السياسيه وفي
الوسط كده اشار الى انه يجب ان نفرق بين
الاتجاه العام والاتجاه الخاص ما معنى
الاتجاه العام ان يكون
لك موقف من فاعل معين من قضيه معينه من
فكره معينه من نظام سياسي معين سواء
بالتاييد او الرفض او شيء من هذا
القبيل والاتجاه الخاص انه هذا النظام
الذي انت تكرهه وتصطدم به اتى بفعل انت
توافق عليه فهذا هو الاتجاه الخاص يعني
مثلا لا شك انه بعد ثوره
52 كان حزب الوفد مختلفا مع
الثوره بالتاكيد ب الثوره حل الاحزاب ثوره
يوليو 52 في مصر بالتاكيد
ولكن لكن ما تذكره الوقائع ان الزعيم
الوفدي الوطني الكبير مصطفى النحاس عندما
امم جمال عبد الناصر قناه السويس اثنى
ثناء شديدا على هذا
القرار لماذا لانه هدف وطني لمصر دافع عنه
الوفد ودافع عنه كل الوطنيين قبل ثوره
يوليو 52 فهذا هو الاتجاه الخاص انت على
خصومه مع ثوره يوليو لكنك في قرار ت من
قناه السويس معها يدا بيد ساطلق هذا على
حماس انا واحد من الناس ا مختلف اختلافا
جذريا مع ايديولوجيه الاخوان المسلمين
وهذا طبعا ينطبق على حماس لانها فرع من
فروع الاخوان المسلمين فهذا هو الاتجاه
العام انا لا اتفق مع ايديولوجيه حماس
السياسيه قد لا اتفق مع ممارستها في قطاع
غزه وكان بعض طلبتي في القطاع ينقلون
لي زمان لما كانوا طلبه عندي يعني ينقلون
لي انتقادات ومعارضات داخل اهل غزه انفسهم
لممارسات حماس فهذا هو الاتجاه العام لكن
عندما تصبح حماس قوه مقاومه للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كلنا يد واحده كلنا يد واحده
وهذا ينطبق انا لا اقول هذا كلام نظريا
هذا ينطبق على الفلسطينيين هل يا استاذ
سيد وانت متابع كثيف لكل ما ينشر عن طوفان
الاقصى هل سمعت
فلسطينيا يقول جاز الله حماس ان فعلت بنا
كذا بالعكس في وسط القصف والتدمير والجراح
وفقدان الاحباب والاصدقاء اي انسان يقول
لك نحن مع المقاومه لماذا لماذا لانه هدف
يجمعنا لان الفلسطيني الذي لا يؤيد حماس
وربما يكون قد عان من بعض ممارساتها يشترك
معها في ان سلطات الاحتلال تذله كل يوم
وتحيل حياته الى جحيم وتقتله و يعني وهي
في كل الاحوال هتبحث حتى لو لم تكن حماس
موجوده سوف تبحث عن سبب اخر لحصار واذلاله
وهكذا بالضب وبالتالي ما اريد قوله انه
بغض النظر لا اريد ان اقول كراهيه بغض
النظر عن الاختلاف مع حماس فان الموقف من
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يوحد جميع
الفلسطينيين
ويوحد جميع المناصرين للقضيه
الفلسطينيه هذا عن النقطه الاولى فيما
يتعلق
بالاستشهاد
بيعني شرائط قديم واشياء من هذا انه حماس
افاد وجودها افاد الاسرائيليين اه يعني
انا اشرت ضمنا انه في البدايه بدا وكان
اسرائيل سعيده بنشاه حماس لكن لماذا سعيده
بنشاه حماس هل لان حماس كيان تابع لها لا
كانت تتصور انه عندما تنشا حماس وتكون
منافسا لمنظمه التحرير فان هذا مبدا فرق
فسد انه ينشطر الفلسطينيون الى شطرين و
متنافسين ويعني ينشغلن بقى عن مواجهه
اسرائيل وهذا للاسف حدث يعني للاسف
اعتبارا من 2007 وحتى وقت قريب هذا للاسف
حدث
فاذا يعني البدايات الاولى التي بدا منها
وكان اسرائيل تؤيد حماس كان القصد منها
تفرقه الصف الفلسطيني وعلينا ان نكون
شديدي الوعي بهذا وعلينا ان
نستغل هذه الممارسات الاسرائيليه البشعه
في توحيد صفوفنا يعني احد المزايا الكبيره
التي يمكن ان نخرج بها من هذه المحنه انه
انا الاوان
للوحده الفلسطينيه ان تتم فانا اعتقد انه
هذه المقوله ثانيه ايضا غير صحيحه ناتي
للنقطه الخاصه بالنتائج
ا طيب يا سيدي حماس فصيل مقاوم اصيل وحققت
انجازات رائعه في بدايه طوفان الاقصى ولكن
ها نحن نرى الان درجه التدمير التي تلحق
بقطاع
غزه
وبالتالي هذا بشكل غير مباشر
ادانه للعمل الذي قامت به مش بس كده اللي
بيتكلم عن ده بيتكلم عن اتاحه الفرصه
لتحقيق حلم تهجير الغزاويين سينا بالضبط
بالضبط بل وقد سمعت في احد الحوارات انه
بعد ان نقضي على حماس ووالى اخره ويتم
التهجير يقوم التطبيع يصبح اسهل نجد حلا
كده سهلا هذا المنطق منطق مغلوط
اولا ما حدث من انجازات في طوفان الاقصى
حتى الان سيسجله التاريخ انا لا ابالغ
انما سيقال ان يوم 7 اكتوبر نجح فصيل
مقاوم فلسطيني بتاييد من الشعب الفلسطيني
في ان يحقق كذا وكذا وكذا وهذا كما قال
الكاتب الاسرائيلي اليسير اليساري جدعون
ليفي قال هذا مزق عباءه الغطرسه
الاسرائيليه هذا شيء لن ينسى لن ينسى ان
حماس اصبح لديها ما يناهز 200 اسير
اسرائيلي وبالتالي هناك اشياء تحققت اذا
وده شان جماعات المقاومه تاريخيا يعني بت
بتلحق بها خسائر كبيره طبعا واشكرك لانك
نقلتني الى النقطه التاليه نقطتي الاولى
كانت ان هناك انجازات محققه تحققت ولن
يؤثر على قيمتها اي تطورات لاحقه
طيب النقطه
الثانيه
انه عندما نراجع خبرات التحرر الوطني سنجد
ما يحدث في غزه والى حد ما في الضفه الان
تكرار
نموذجي لخبرات التحرر الوطني انا ادعو
الذين يقولون هذا الى قراءه تاريخ الثوره
الجزائريه
وتتبع السلوك
الفرنسي الذي كان يستخدم الطائرات في
محاوله لاباده الشعب الجزائري احنا اليوم
بنتكلم حتى الان على حوالي 7000 شهيد
فلسطين في غزه
طيب حدثني عن حرب التحرير الجزائريه بعد
نهايتها التي تسمى حرب المليون شهيد
واخوانا في الجزائر يقولون المليون
ونصف كيف حدث هذا حدث من ممارسات
استعماريه بشعه والشعب الجزائري تحمل ودفع
تضحيات هائله فماذا كانت النتيجه حرب
التحرير الاخيره التي اطلقت الرصاص الاولى
فيها في نوفمبر
1954 حققت هدف الاستقلال التام في يوليو
62 يعني بعد تان سنوات اذا خبره التاريخ
تقول لنا ان ما يحدث في غزه الان حدث من
قبل عديد المرات عديد
المرات نتذكر تجارب
مثل الحرب الامريكيه في فيتنام
الم تكن التضحيات
هائله الغزو الامريكي لافغانستان سنه 2001
الذي استمر 20 عاما ثم انتهى بانسحاب
القوات الامريكيه وتسليم افغانستان الى
الفصيل الذي غزت افغانستان من اجل
اقصاه نتذكر الشعب في جنوب افريقيا
الاستيطان الذي بدا في القرن الثا ولم
ينتهي الا في العقد الاخير من القرن العشر
كم التضحيات التي تحملها الشعب في جنوب
افريقيا ثم انتهى الامر
بالاستقلال اذا خبره التاريخ تقول لا
تعاير بالخسائر قلوبنا طبعا مع اهلنا في
غزه وما يتحملونه من تضحيات لكني اريد ان
اقول ان هذا هو منطق التاريخ لا هو فعل
حماس ولا غير حماس هذا منطق الصراع بين
الشعوب المستعمره وبين
مستعمر نقطتي الاخيره انه
اولا الحرب في غزه لم تحسب نتائجها
النهائيه بعد نحن نتكلم في توقيت يقال فيه
ان اسرائيل تنوي القيام بعمليه بريه شامله
وهناك
تحليلات كثيره تقول قول ان هذا سوف يكون
عملا في منتهى الخطوره والصعوبه اذا هناك
جوله بعد جوله القصف العشوائي الهمجي لغزه
ما زالت هناك جوله انا لا اريد ان اتنبا
باشياء
لا قبل لي بمعرفه معطياتها بالتفصيل انما
المنطق يقول وهو منطق ليس فقط العرب
المتعاطفين مع اهلنا في فلسطين او منطق
الفلسطينيين ولكنه منطق المحللين
العسكريين الغربيين انه على الاقل احد
السيناريوهات انا لا اقطع بان هذا سيحدث
لكن ادرع الى الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يحدث
انه احد السيناريوهات ان المعركه البريه
اذا شاءوا اجتياح غزه سوف تكرر ما تم يوم
7 اكتوبر حماس لديها تحصيناتها ولديها كذا
طيب لنفرض لا قدر الله ان السيناريو
الثاني حدث وهو ان تنجح اسرائيل في اعاده
السيطره على قطاع غزه وان بخسائر كبيره
ولكنها لا تستطيع ان توقف اسرائيل لنفرض
ان هذا
حدث ان للباطل جوله وحروب
التحرير عباره عن جولات متعدده متتاليه
فيها انتصارات وفيها هزائم لكن لم يحدث لم
يحدث في اي حرب تحرير منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ان انتهت حرب تحرير بهزيمه الشعب
المحتل المستعمر الى اخر هذه الامور
وبالتالي اسوا الاحتمالات لا قدر الله ان
تنتهي هذه الجوله لصالح اسرائيل هذا سيكون
هذه ستكون نتيجه مؤقته المنظور التاريخي
ستكون مؤقته غزه قد تصمت شهرا سنه 10 سنين
بل اكثر لكن لا يمكن القضاء على اراده
المقاومه لا في غزه ولا في
فلسطين جزيل الشكر معالي الدكتور واستاذن
انت اشرت في النهايه الى السيناريوهات
المحتمله لاي اجتياح اسرائيلي لغزه لكن
هذا يتطلب او يحتاج ان احنا نفصله في حلقه
اخرى ان سمح وقتك ان شاء الله
جزيل الشكر معال الدكتور الله يخليك شكرا
جزيلا لحضراتكم ومع الدكتور احمد يوسف ان
شاء الله نستانف تحليل ما يجري في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله وفي غيرها من القضايا
العربيه اشكركم والى اللقاء